小伙伴,大家好,我是本次玛丽全开特辑的讲师,毕生编译器SMPR技术专家王涛
很高兴和大家在CAN训练营玛丽全开特辑的直播间见面
2026的CAN训练营,我们设置了全新的四大主题课程
分别是开源技术系列,玛丽全开特辑,开二主说和企业对话专场
同时也设置了很多好玩的互动,让各位小伙伴参与
下面给大家介绍一下本季全新的训练玩法,大家可以截图保存
玩法一,直播开始后,观看直播并在活动issue页下方评论答题
按照时间排名,回答正确的签误名可领取奖品
玩法二,课后作业,直播后完成课后作业并在此issue下方评论答题
按照时间排名,全部回答正确且答案格式正确的签误名可领取定制茅台一份
玩法三,学习笔记加直播打卡
观看Kent训练营课程直播回放军可
根据课程内容,总结学习心得发布至深层论坛
并在Kent Learning Hub 开源仓提交issue
好,我们回到主题
我们本次的课程主题是
Triton深层性核扩展编程介绍
接下来我会从编程扩展设计
CMPI编译原理扩展编程介绍
以及高性能案例介绍,这四个维度给大家介绍
在开始了解课程之前,我们先了解一下
我们给到深层性核编程设计的基本原则和背景
首先我们为什么要发布一套深层性核的编程呢
首先我们Triton社区已经提供了一系列的接口
我们的Triton language,可以接在Triton官网上获取
但是这一套接口其实都是基于我们Tensor类型的操作
然后我们的接口的输入输出其实都是基于Tensor进行操作的
好处就是它是在生成TTI的时候都是以SSA链路方便我们编辑分析
但是SSA无法表达我们片上内存服用
所以我们在此基础上推出了我们的Chrome Extension
然后这一系列接口它可以操作Memoref类型支持片上内存层设计Layout
以及非SSA支持片上内存服用表达
我们使用了ToTensor,ToBuffer允许Tensor和Buffer进行交互
然后基于这一类API我们其实就可以更加底层的进行像一些内存服用
并且我们可以自己控制我们各个内存进行的Layout
对于一些追求极致性能的用户来说是一个非常好的接口
然后同时我们也提供了一下SN Language这些特有的OP
比如像一些核心同步的控制
然后CV类仅有核拷贝的操作
然后提到CV类仅有核拷贝的话
其实就是在我们的950
生存950系列上面我们从UB到就是FactCore和CubeCore之间
我们提供的直接通入不像我们的LSN代记
只能FactCore和CubeCore之间交互只能通过Space进行交互
然后当9550系列开始使用的时候我们用户可以直接通过
我们的高级API直接控制
直接从AerCore搬到ZCore
这样的话一个是我们可以减少我们编辑的一些分析
并且如果是用户直接控制的话
就是对于一些Kernel可能用户会比我们编辑更加了解
因为毕竟编辑是一个泛化的优化
然后当用户对于某些Kernel
就是想要进一步优化的时候
可以使用像这些生存的扩展接口
然后可以看到我们这里有一个图
然后最上层就是一个Triton
然后就Triton原生的一些Language
然后以此基础上我们推出了一些像BuffAPI/API
CompileHint之类
然后再往下就是我们生存特有的一些扩展OP
就像我刚刚提到的像CV经验核和CV核延同步
然后这下面一层就是我们的CNPI
然后它也分多个层级
像预处理进入后层核印射层内存印射层
处理单元直立印射层
然后可以看到我们从上到下其实越往上我们的用性越高
越往下性能越好
但同时越往下我们的复杂度就越高
因为我们更加偏向底层
所以说对于想要使用这一系列的API人可能需要对我们的生存硬件也需要有更好了解
但是这些OP只是说
它的用处有两我理解有两个方面
一方面就是对于追求极致性能的用户来说我们可以通过这些高级API对于一类特定的 kernel进行特定优化
还有一部分就是像我们像我们的编辑器
因为大部分的优化其实都进行在我们编辑器内部
我们可以通过这些高级接口
提前摸索一些性能优化性能优化的方向
然后机械进行穿刺
然后可以了解到某个方案对于某一些场景的性能提升到底有多少
这样的话我们也方便我们编辑器更好的更好的集成一些通用的性能优化特性
好
然后我们大概过一下今天会涉及到的接口
第一类是BufferAPI
BufferAPI就是我们可以直接相比较于Tensor的话我们可以更灵活的操纵我们平常内存
第一个Allog就是我们直接分配片上的内存
然后我们片上也是分层级的
就是我们因为在深圳线内部内存也是分各个层级
像L1UB还有L0A20B后面我们会相细的介绍
然后SubView的话其实就是我们对一个大的MREF大的Buffer
然后进行一个指示图的获取
然后这一步是不会进行任何消耗的
只是说我们会获取一个大Buffer的一个指图
然后ToBuffer就很好了解
我们需要将一个Tensor转成对应的Buffer
ToTensor就是将Buffer转成Tensor
然后StyleX API就是我们有两个StyleXS和InsertStyleX
StyleX跟我们的SubView其实有点类似
但是唯一的区别就是我们是一个是操纵Buffer一个是操纵Tensor
然后并且SubView的话它是一个不会带来任何消耗的一个 API
但是StyleXStyleX它可能会在某个阶段将StyleXS的操作
变成一个UB或者别的内存层级的一个拷贝
然后InsertStyleX也比较好
就是从一个将一个小的Tensor转入到一个大的Tensor中
然后第三个API就是Scope API
Scope API是为了指定某一个区域内所有的Operation是属于哪一个Scope
这个Scope其实大概就是有两类
一个是CubeCore 一个是FedCore
然后我们这样用一个Scope包住以下的所有的Operation的话
那代表下面所有操作都属于CubeCore或者FedCore
然后接下来一个是Compare Hint
Compare Hint的话其实就是我们给到一个编译选项信息
然后这个的作用会非常广泛
就是我们可以像某一些优化场景
只对于特定的场景会有优化
但是对于部分场景可能甚至会有劣化
这样的话我们可以使用Compare Hint
然后通过用户通过上层
通过Python的Kernel告诉编辑
你你想要使用使能这个优化
这个时候编辑会根据你给到的Hint去使能对应的实现
然后不同的Hint
它会有不同的功能也或者会有不同的性能油画点
然后后面的话我会举一个例子
但Hint的话会有很多
本次的话也不会把所有的Hint介绍
介绍完
然后后面接口就是深藤清合接口
就是会更加的偏向于我们深藤的特有加速
然后这两个前两个subject ID和subject number的话
其实就是我们在我们的深藤芯片内部
Fight Core跟Cube Core
一个Cube Core会对应两个Fight Core
然后subject ID代表就是我们当前这个Fight Core的ID
然后Number的话一般情况下是2
但是不排除有特定场景
我们可能会有一比N的场景
但是在物理层面的话Cube Core跟Fight Core的比例一直都是一比二
然后下面两个ThinkBroadSet和ThinkBroadWeight就是
C跟V核间同步的设置
SyncBlockAll的话是一个核间全同步
这个接口的性能会比较差
一般是在我们进行进度调试或者Transition的时候用的
后面两个接口的话就是我们的仅偶和同步
Copy from UB to L1就是我们从UB将一块Block从UB搬到L1
FacePath的话就是我们将我们的AIC里面的一块Buff搬到我们的AIB
好我们开始下一页
然后我们可以做一个总结
就是扇子自定义快速调试
兼容Triton提供升腾清合编程接口
支持扇子开发的自定义快速调试
然后我们提供这些偏程接口的背景
就是我们可以通过这些接口
给到用户
然后用户可以
自定义
就是用户可以自己写出来一些编译器
才能做到的一些优化点
对于某些场景
比如某个kernel或者某个新的扇子
编译器
当前编译器没有识别出来这个优化点时
用户可以通过我们提供的清合接口
在kernel层面使能这些优化
然后总结下去就是兼容Triton扩展
清合编程接口
编译器支持
首次一体优化
支持自动化
同时也支持扇子开发
手动显示
控制CV盒流水变形
CV盒EBL配比
以及VIX的模式选取能力
对于变种复杂
扇子支持扇子开发的手动
极致性能优化
其实就是我们编译器既可以自动进行一些CV类
或者一些复杂场景的优化
同时也提供编译接口
给到可以通过在算子层面的改写
使能一些优化点
然后至于有哪些优化点的话
可以从可以下面看到
一个是控制CV
Tripline流水变形
就是我们
我们可以通过在算子层面的改写
写出来像Preload
像CPULining
这样的
并行
执行
就是CV流水并行的执行
DSL
这样的话
我们就可以
在编译器没有使能这种
场景的情况下
对一些复杂扇子进行改写
然后快速
释放
快速释放算力
快速的
使能使一个扇子得到极致性的
第二个
显示控制CV和EBR配比
就是刚刚我说到的话
在物理层面
我们一个FateCore
我们一个CubeCore
其实是对应两个FateCore
当有些场景我们编译器
没办法分析出来
对应的FateCore
可以切分的情况下
我们可以通过
DSL层面的改写
去显示的控制
CV核的配比
第三个就是我们可以显示的控制
CV分离
加CMD
CMT模式选择
我们可以使用
之前我提到的Scope的API
告诉编译器
在这个Scope内部的所有的操作
都是来自于CubeCore
或者是FateCore
并且如果在FateCore内部
我们也可以去选择到底使用CMD
还是CMT指令
第三点
我们可以显示的控制MultiBuffer
这个MultiBuffer
其实也是一个流水并行的开关
但是
区别于CVPIPLINE的流水并行
它是单个核内的并行
然后这个其实
这个MultiBuffer也只是CompideHint的一种
CompideHint有很多使用场景
并且我们也提供了很多的
怎么算
去告诉我编译器
或者很多的Hint
去告诉编译器想要使用的某些场景
OK
在我们详细介绍扩展编程接口之前
我们可以先快速的过一下我们的Sign NPR
编译原理
然后方便大家去更好的了解
如何使用这些接口
并且为什么要使用这些接口
然后第一点其实就是我们Sign NPR
抽象哪些能力
Sign NPR到底在做些什么
它其实就是面向生存
提供一个完备的抽象能力
然后它抽象哪些呢
一个是抽象了核内的资源管理
就比如内存的分配
比如
横布
就像刚刚我们的一些高级API一样
我们
提供了一些
接口
允许给到用户
他可以自己去分配内存
自己去成功
但是理论上
当前
如果是只用Traten社区的语言
这些所有能力都是集成在我们的
Sign NPR内部的
同时
仅描述
切块逻辑
就是我们的
我们的Traten其实面向快编程
我们只考虑当前这块在
坑头是如何执行的
Sign NPR其实也是
也是
这么做的
同时
屏蔽的CO格式
地址
对齐
CV
再过分离
等编程通电问题
这里的CO格式
其实就是我们
在我们的
升能内部
如果使用Metamount操作是需要使用NZ格式的
但是我们在
Global Memory上排布一般都是ND的格式
但是我们
不会让用户去感知这些格式的转换
我们一般都是在我们编辑内部进行一些这些格式的推导
然后屏蔽这些复杂的操作
用户只需要
用
用户只需要感知到这两块Tensor的大小
和输入输出的大小是什么样子
就可以
就可以达到它想要的效果
需要显示进行格式的转换
然后地址的对齐就是在我们的
在我们的深层的
LocalBuff内
它对它的地址是按照我们一个
一个Data或者一个字节
去对齐的
它很多场景下都是需要我们
满足一个Block
就是一个32字节对齐的场景
当用户的Tensor不满足这个情况下
我们会
我们会在片上进行自动的对齐
然后CV架构的分离
其实就是我们
CubeCore跟FactCore是分离的
在ALA3代价
我们我们的
E跟V的交互只能放在
GlobalMemory上的Workspace
我们需要自己分配
我们需要在GlobalMemory上分配一块内存
作为Workspace
给到C跟V进行交互
然后在950代价
我们可以
直接有有直接的同路可以从
AIC往AIV搬或者AIV往AIC搬
然后这部分的话用户也不用本质
比如用户写一个DOT
写一个DOT
T2.DOT再加T2.Add
它不需要显示的去
说我们要把MathMod之后的结果搬到
UB内
然后再进行Add
这些操作都是由我们编辑企业去控制的
但是与此同时我们提供了高级API
如果用户想要进行极致性的优化
想要非常细颗粒的控制
我们也是可以我们也是提供了接口的
这就是我们当前需要我们给到这些API的作用之一
同时我们做了一个手自一体化
就新增了IoT1方圆
用于标记属性
支持手自一体化精细颗粒度控制是否乒乓时能地址类企
像刚刚这个乒乓流水其实就是我刚刚说的
就是我们有一个companing叫multibuff
它的目的就是为了控制乒乓流水
是核内的流水可以冰进去了
我们看一下我们的HeavyMod的设计
HeavyMod如果之前大家听过SMPI的介绍的话
应该知道
HeavyMod是我们SMPI中的一层
就一个方言
HeavyM方言的话是
更偏向于我们的生存
硬件的硬件相关的一些
操作
比如像我们抽象的计算同步单英类操作
屏蔽硬件细节
我们将硬件的指令抽象到我们的HeavyMod内部
然后抽象了片上内存同步关于值
其实我们可以刚刚可以看到那些
像高阶
API中的内存
alloc
或者同步
最后都会运输成对应的HeavyModP
同时抽象
CubeVetco混合架构
我们会将
因为C跟V是分离的
我们会将一个面扇子拆分
拆分成两个kernel
然后进行
然后生成两个kernel进行优化之后
生成
但是生成最后的奥银质还是会将两个
但是优化的时候我们会分开来优化
下面的话就是一个最简单的一个HeavyMOP的Kernel
然后可以看到其实就是两个load
从GlobalMemory搬到我们的LocalBuffer
就是我们的Vector计算单元中进行Vadd
然后再搬出
然后这些碰点问题的话其实就是一个是自动乘除于推导
自动乘除于它的目的就是我们芯片的LocalBuffer是分层的
我们比如我们的Factor计算是在Ub上UnifiedBuffer
但是我们的MathMod操作我们是需要将数据先搬到L1上
然后这些推导都是由我们的边缘体自动推导出来
当然我们现在提供了高级API
可以在DSL在TradingCode层面自动自己去分配对应Buffer的内存和内存层级
但是如果用户不用这些高级API
我们的边缘体也是可以自动推导出来
然后自动地址对齐就是我刚刚说的
由于我们的LocalBuffer的地址需要满足Block对齐
就是32字节对齐
当不满足的时候我们需要自动去推导
然后MixStand自动分离
然后就是我们的一个大的MixCode
我们需要把它分离成一个CubeCode和两个
一个CubeCode和一个FedCode
但是由于我们的配比物理上配比是1:2
我们还需要将我们的FedCode
它的空调进行一个在此切分
这样才我们才可以充分使能
我们升腾的算力
好我们现在看一下我们的比较关键的一个油画
就是CB流水冰性油画
然后我们可以看一下这个架构图
这是我们的950硬件架构图
然后可以看到上面这一块就是AIC
就是我们的CubeCode
下面是AIV
是我们的FedCode
可以看到在950代记
我们的L1和UB是有通路的
并且我们Cube计算完的结果
也是可以通过FedCode
传到我们的UB上
并且但是它的架构依然是分离的
就是说它们有一个经级额同路
并且配比1:2
对于编译的挑战
其实我在上语面也介绍过了
然后这次这个界面
我们主要介绍我们CVE是如何进行流水并行的
在我们编辑内部是如何做的
并且后面我们也是可以通过在坑洞层面的改写
去使能这个流水并行
然后我们以FleshAttention为例
FleshAttention其实就是在计算
我们可以把它分成四层
CubeFactorCubeFactor
在这如果它是一个串群的流水
那我们就是说
我们因为它数据都是有依赖的
我们先需要计算完D0
就是第一个Cube计算
然后将第一个Cube计算的结果
给到第一个Fact计算就是Feeding
然后将第一个Feeding的计算结果
再传给第二个Cube
Cube就是C1
然后最后算完再给到V1
然后由于有数据一览
串群流水必须得是C0
V0
C1
V1
然后假设我们有5次迭代
那我们流水
我们的流水就是按照D0
V0
C1
V1
然后
拷购5份
然后这个就是我们的串群流水
但是我们迭代跟迭代之间的C0
跟C0
V0
是没有数据依赖的
我们想要使能我们的CV流水
并行
那我们
我们其实有两个方向
一个是C5
就是CV流水
并行
还有就是preload
然后我们可以看到看第一个
第一pimeline的话
其实它的目的就是
一次发射4个C0
这样的话
当我们第一个C0计算完之后
我们的第一个V0开始发射
那与此同时
我们第二个C0
其实就可以发射
因为我们第二个C0
并不会依赖于V0
或者第一个C0
我们只要第一个
只要这个时候
我们的cubecore
是一个空闲的状态
那我们就可以发射第二个C0
那这个时候可以看到
我们的C0跟V0
就是并行发射了
然后
一次类推
然后当第一个V0计算完之后
第二个V0
可以开始工作
然后与此同时
我们的
四个C0
都没有数据来
只要
前面的C0
结束
我们的空闲
开始空闲了
那我们的C0
就可以开始工作
当所有的C0
工作完
计算完
那我们可以
并且第一个V0
已经早就计算完了
那我们就开始
可以开始
第一个C1
然后以此类推
这样的话
我们的C跟V的流水
就完全变形起来了
但是这个时候
我们会发现
我们最后一个迭代
依然会存在的信号
因为这个C5
我们只是同时发射了四分
当我们有五次迭代的时候
我们最后一个
我们最后一个迭代
依然是按照
串行之行
但是尽管如此
我们的流水
已经会比上面的串行
好了接近一倍
如果想要对C5
进行更好的优化
我们就需要
使能Plow
Plow的话
Plow的方案
会比较复杂
我们在这里
就不详细介绍了
但是它的
好处也非常明显
你可以看到
相比于上面的C5
我们又接近优化了10%
然后这两个优化点
我们在
首先我们会在
编辑器内部
进行使能
但是编辑器内部的功能
更偏向于泛化
用户
如果用户对于某一个
特定的kernel
想要有特定的流水排布
就可以用到我们的GOTI API
进行我们的CV的流水排布
然后尽可能的释放我们的算力
好我们下一面
下面我们来介绍一下
1比2的优化
然后1比2的优化
主要就是因为
我们的cube核和fix核
在物理上的配比是
一个cube核
配上两个vesicle
这样的话
我们就需要
在我们的编辑器内部
进行
对fix核的切分
然后我们就以
以下代码为例
我们做了一个esp加abs
然后搬出
然后并且它的tensor是一个64
如果在1比2使人成功的情况下
可以看到我们会需要
获取到我们的subblockid
也就是一般的话就是0跟1
就是我们的fix核和fix核和fix核一核
分别处理一半的数据
然后再在DM上进行拼接
可以看到我们这里会有一个stressize
将一个64的tensor
抽取32个出来
然后它抽取的偏移
是基于我们的subblockid
也就是说我们两个fix核分别抽取一半
然后进行计算
然后并且在我们的DM上进行拼接
然后当1比2使能失败的情况下
我们
我们会只有一个核进行工作
只有0核进行工作
另一个核它是在空转的情况下
这种情况的话
我们的算力就是没有被完全使能
然后可以看到这个是IS面
当我们提供了高级API
在TritonLanguage上进行扩展
生存核的API之后
我们可以手动的写出来这种逻辑
比如像这个getsubblockid
我们这里也提供了subfix核这个接口
subfix核就是
vector的数量
这里就是2
然后extress test insert test
我们都是也提供对应接口
我们完全可以通过前端的写法
去使能一比较优化
当然编辑器其实已经将大部分场景cover住了
但是如果出现某些非常极端的场景
或者非常特殊的kernel
我们就可以通过前端的改写去进行1比20
OK
接下来我会详细介绍一下
我们当前提供的
变成建口以及量力
然后第一个是就是我们的Buffer API Alloc
Alloc GumiC就是我们分配一块平常内存
并且要指定地处空间
因为我们内存是一个分级的
刚刚我们也看到了我们的G50代机的内存布局
内存存级是很多的
包括了L1,L0,H,L0,B,L0,C
U,B,我们可以通过这个Alloc的API去进行直接的分配
就可以减少我们电影器内部的推导
同时如果一个用户对他的Kernel非常了解的话
也可以通过Alloc进行一些不必要的
就是不必要的内存分配
或者一些不必要的内存分配
或者一些机制的性能优化
可以看到我们参数的话其实就是比较简单
这块内存的数据类型
就常规的像Floot32,Unit32之类的
Shape的话也比较好类型是这块内存的大小
然后addressBase其实就是我们指定当前的地址的空间到底是处于哪一个内存存级
然后返回值的话就是一块Buffer
然后这里的样力可以看到Floot32,SBlock,Floot32数据类型,SBlock就是一个Size大小
然后后面的addressBase,UB,L1,L0A,L0B,L0C
这个就是我们片场类似层级,MAY
不同的类似层级对应不同的功能
UB的话其实就是我们需要进行FET操作
L1的话就是MATMOT操作的路口
然后L0A就做几转,L0B就几转,L0C就输出MATMOT
SubView的话其实可以理解成它是一个IR扩展到了
就是MIR的一个operation扩展到了我们的Buffer API内
它就是一个对一块Buffer进行创建一个仔细图
然后理论上SubView是不会产生任何消耗的
它只是对一个内存层级的一个获取
然后我们看到它对应的参数是Source
就是它这块DeadBuffer
Offset每个维度的偏移量
Dead每个维度的大小
Stead每个维度的不长
这几个参数可以跟MIR市区上SubViewOperation的参数
一一对应起来
然后据用法的话
其实你可以看到我们Alloc完一个Buffer之后
这块Buffer进行一个仔细图的获取
在一块下一个Buffer API叫做ToBuffer
它的目的也比较简单
就是我们可以将一块Tensor转化成Buffer
转化成Buffer的目的就是Tensor没办法处理的一些场景
我们Buffer是可以处理的
比如像类传服用
类传共享
对应参数我们也看一下
第一个就是Tensor
我们就是这样一个Tensor
想要转换Tensor
Space就是我们Buffer所在的地理空间
就是主在哪一块内存层级
第三个就是我们
第三个内存
第三个可能是一块一样的
都是内存空间
都是我们片上的内存层级
可以看到下面的用法
我们先弄用Tensor转据原有的Language
T2.4
它生成了一个Tensor
然后我们将这块Tensor进行一个ToBuffer
ToBuffer之后我们再对
ToBuffer之后
我们就获取到了A Tensor对应的Buffer
OK
我们再去看一下
我们的ToTensor这块
这个API
这也比较简单
我们换Square
其实就是这样一块Buffer
这样一块MemRap
MemRap
其实就是我们Ir中
Ir中对Buffer的一个描述
我们将Buffer转换成对应的T2Tensor对象
反过来就是一个Tensor
其实就是Aloc出来的结果
做一个ToTensor
OK我们下面就是我们的Blast API
第一个HRSS从大的Tensor中抽取一个小Tensor
之前也提到HRSS的作用跟我们的StarView有点类似
唯一的区别就是StarView处理是MemRap
是Buffer
但HRSS是一个Tensor
然后我们过一下它的参数
然后参数的话其实你可以看到跟SubView有点类似
Sauce就是对应的大Tensor
Obset,Sat,Stread都跟SubView是一样的
唯一的区别就是能处理对象是一块Tensor
并且SubView它是没有任何的消耗
它不会映射成我们对应的指令
但是Stress在经过一系列的Ir转换之后
它可能会变成一个LocalBuffer内的Copy
它的范围值就是一块新的Tensor
从一块大Tensor中抽取一块小Tensor
用法的话也是比较简单
我们给定Tensor
OffsetSat跟Stread之后就可以复制到一个Tensor
并且这个HRSSDance在MemR中也是有对应的
就是MemR社区直接提供的
Operation它是直接有对应的
对应的Ir,对应的op的
所以说我们在这里
用
用我们的TritonLanguage
扩展的TritonLanguage写出来之后
它会直接映射成MemR社区的HRSS
InsertSat跟SSS作用相反
它是这样一块小的Tensor
插入到一个大的Tensor
然后唯一的区别其实就是我们
原始Tensor和代查数的Tensor
我们就两块Tensor
然后其他的Tensor都是跟SSS类似
然后用法的话其实就是
只是说我们需要获取到两个Tensor
然后将
然后并且将两个Tensor
传给对应的InsertStats
然后一个是大Tensor一个小Tensor
我们需要
给到对应的ObsetStats
Stats
但这里需要考虑的是
在我们的LocalBuff内部
内存是按照32字节
或者一个Block大小去排布的
假设我们在前端写出来一个
在一个FaderT地址上
进行一个插入
很可能就会导致有一些
意想不到的问题发生
比如我们会报一些Runtime Error
所以说始终这些
我们深层扩展的一些API
是需要对我们的芯片
有一定程度了解
不然的话会出现很多
想象不到的问题
Scope就是划定一个区域
并标识信息
然后我们这里的目的就是
在Scope内部
所有的操作都属于
它自不转
指定的
指定的区域
比如当前我们这个Load
它是在一个FactScope内部
这个时候编辑就会认为
这个Load一定是往Ubin进行搬运
因为它是属于FactCore
下面的话就是如果是在一个CubeScope内
那我们就会判断
下面所有的操作都是在Cube内部进行实现的
这样的话会减少我们编辑的推导
并且
就像之前我们进行Cube流水排布的时候
我们可以直接在DSR内部指定对应的C跟V
这样的话
可以快速的排布流水
并且可以减少编译期的编译分析
中文字幕志愿者 李宗盛
这个assend API的话就是我们对应的subblockID和subblockNumber
subblockID的话就是我们因为我们cubecall和faitcall的配比是1比2
那我们每一个factor都是有对应的一个ID
也就是说我们是合0还是合1
然后subblockNumber的话就是我们当前
到底是1比2还是1比N
1比N的话就是它因为我们物理核是1比2
但是我们逻辑上我们可以是1比任何
只要你想只要只要说用户觉得当前的当前你想要
你可以循环使用这两个factor
这样的话就可以变成1比N
但这个就取决于用户想怎样使用
接下来介绍一下hint
然后hint就比较关键
因为它的作用非常多
取决于我们编辑器给到的能力
然后接下来我会以两个hint为例
给介绍一下hint到底有哪些作用
然后第一个是b2s mask
然后这个hint的作用就是一个布尔类型
IE的tensor在globalmemory中其实是按照i8去进行存储的
但是我们在比如我们在我们的片上我们想要使用一个t2.ware
然后根据它的condition去进行选择
然后这condition是想要按照真正的int
一个比特一个比特进行排布
但是假设我们将这块tensor从globalmemory中进行搬入
这个时候它直接搬进来的时候
它依然是按照int8排布
也就是说你一个字节只有一个比特
一个字节只有一个比特是有效
有效数据其他都是无效的
或者说卡路是0
那我们在片上还是得进行一次数据类型转换
比如说我们load完之后
即使我们直接在这里将condition给到这个位
我们编析内部依然会做的一个
进行一个自动的数据类型转换
将这个int8的condition cast成int1
然后再进行位
这个时候如果用户对这个condition进行一个compile hint的
标记表示
这个condition我们已经在
他们就是用户已经在globalmemory中进行
一比特位就是IE的排布
然后即使它还是按照i8进行搬入
但是它的数据分布是按照IE的
这个时候我们就不会进行数据类型的cast
我们会直接使用传入进来的数据的二进制进行condition
然后并且进行比特位的选择
这样的话我们可以减少我们的减少我们在片上的数据类型转换
减少我们的fait计算
并且如果我们的mask在kern内部计算的场景非常
就是计算数非常多这个mask非常复杂
其实我们都是建议在kern外部进行一个或者它是一个静态的mask
我们我们可以直接在globalmemory中进行一个拼接
传入之后直接使用
会比我们在kern上进行一个再进行计算会好很多
但是并不是所有场景都是这样子
我们还是这只是提供了一种选择
可以让用户选择到底使能是否要使能这个优化项
然后第二就是一个enable ice
inable ice的话其实就是我们在不管是tratin社区也好
还是说mii也好
对于i4其实都是没有一个直接的表达的
但是深层内部深层硬件它又是支持了intest的metamod指令
这个时候我们为了就是用户如果用户想要使能这个s的metamod的话就可以通过这个hint告诉编辑
当前这个dot是一个intest的dot
然后它的其他的操作比如搬入搬出
依然可以使用不管是int8还是int16
它的搬入依然是可以使用其他设计队形
但是我们在metamod的时候我们会进行int4的metamod
ok所以说这个hint的作用就是一个是为了使能编译器的某个优化
或者是为了直接将对应的信息传给编译器
然后进行一些特定场景的优化
所以说它的功能是非常强大的
但同时也是很复杂的
因为不同的hint它会有不同的能力
然后用户想要了解所有的hint的话
其实也是一个非常困难的事情
所以说编辑器的话也是尽可能的减少这些hint的
使用会尽可能将放含能力做到编辑内部
接下来就介绍一下我们的同步
它是一个合间同步
合间同步的目的其实就是
刚刚我流水图里面也可以看到
比如我们c跟v有数据依赖
那也就是说我们必须vector开始
必须依赖于我们的cube算完之后
vector才能开始计算
不然肯定会有进度问题
因为你get核的数据是依赖于
cube核数据计算完的
这时候就会用到我们的合间同步
当用户使用Traden社区自由的language写出来
像dot add reduce之类的操作的情况下
我们的合间同步会根据我们的IR去自动推导
但也就是说用户想要手动的去排流水
手动的去控制制
公布
这个时候我们就可以用到
以上的几个API进行手动的控制
还有我们可以过一下参数
然后第一个参数就是我们的发射方
如果是AIC就是cube
如果是AIV就是vict
第二个是接受方
也是cube跟vict
然后下面一个就是一个核心的全同步
然后核心的全同步
然后核心的全同步的话一般
也就是核心的全同步
然后核心的全同步
然后下面一个就是一个核心的全同步
然后核心的全同步的话一般
然后下面一个就是核心的全同步
下面一个就是核心的全同步
然后核心的全同步的话一般代表所有的cube
所有的vict
或者所有的核心上完之后才能开始下一步操作
所以上代表演示性的会比较差
然后这是一个样例
我们可以看到
我们
嗯
我们在这里使用了
think block set think block weight
这两个
接口
代表的就是
我们必须
这个
后面的vector计算
必须得等待上面的
cube计算
结束之后才开始
所以说我们在这里手动
插了这个核心筒
然后可以看到上面的
cube代表的是
是load dot
加store
然后后面的
vector计算
代表了load
加法
加store
然后我们通过在
titan层面
手动写出来这个核心筒
进行我们的核心筒
我们的核心筒
插入
然后后面
这里的话
代表的是我们的
核心筒
然后也是
all cube
all fit
all
或者
all sub
fit
然后
然后接下来
介绍一下我们的
进入核心筒
接下来
介绍一下我们的
进入核心筒
copy from ub to l1
和 facecap
其实就是
将我们
vector
和内部的数据
搬到我们的
cube核中
然后cube
我们想要进行
cube计算的时候
都需要将数据
无论是从 ub
还是从 jm
都需要提前搬到
l1
内部才能开始cube计算
那我们想要进行
coop计算的时候
都需要将数据
无论是从 ub
还是从 jm
都需要提前搬到
l1
内部才能开始
coop计算
然后参入的话就就是Source,就是AIV核上的UB,AIV核上的Tensor或者Buff,Dest其实就是我们的LE上的一个内存。
然后第二个是FacePipe,FacePipe其实就是将我们的数据从Cube核搬到Fet核。
然后Cube核的话其实就是我们将我们MateMod计算完结果从L0CFacePipe直接搬回到UB,然后再进行Vent计算。
然后参数的话其实Source就是我们的AIC核上的Tensor或者Buff,Dest就是AIV核上的Tensor或者Buff。
然后后面的话你还看到还有新拷展的两个参数DMMOD和DUINODESMOD。
这两个其实第一个的话其实就是我们的Layout的转换,就是我们刚刚提到的。
像这些Layout一般的话就是我们会在编析内部进行一个推导。
比如我们从GM到IAE就是ND2NZ,然后这里的话我们可以控制FacePipe出来结果到底是NZ2ND。
或者说你不想转换成ND,你还是想继续用NZ排布,你也可以在这里进行控制。
然后这个参数的话其实目的就是我们选择到底是搬到一个Face核还是搬到多个Face核。
因为我们的配比其实是预标的。
然后可以看一下我们的样例。
然后常规的搬入计算,去Buffer,类材分配。
然后将计算完的结果从UB搬到11。
Face核也是。
LoadAlloc代表我们的是一个UB内的Buffer。
然后FacePipe将一块将这块Tensor搬到UB上。
OK,以上就是我本次介绍的所有的接口。
然后后面的话我会介绍一下一个高性能样例介绍一下我们如何使用这些接口进行优化。
首先我们需要知道了在什么长眼下,到底使用哪些接口。
这个时候我们就需要通过分析仿制流水和中间RD进行定位,
然后进行手改TradenSign+编语化进行调优。
然后就是我们开发者可以通过,就是我们首先我们可以先用我们的Traden社区的language进行根据算法写出来一个kernel。
然后这个时候我们这时候性能一般相对而言会比较差。
这个时候我们就可以通过一些流水图和Dump中间,中间RD进行调试定位,判断到底性能平景点在哪里。
然后通过Traden社区原有的一些优化方案比如AutoTure,然后Traden优化还是进行我们的高级API使用。
然后接下来就是我过一下我们我们常见的优化场景以及调游手段。
然后比如我们逻辑核第一个,比如逻辑核数过多,调度开较大。
这一类场景是比较多的,因为我们生产相对于GPU的话,我们的物理核数是比较少的。
比如我们物理核数只有48个Fact核,但是这个时候,但如果我们直接向GPU的Tradenkernel直接迁移到我们的生产。
这个时候它逻辑核会开的比较多,比如一千两千三千都是有可能的。
如果我们按照它的逻辑核进行分核的话,每一次的每个核我们都会需要有同复的调度开向。
这时候我们就需要我们的手改Traden扇子在Tradenkernel内部进行一个破循环的展开。
当然我们编器其实也提供了对应的能力,需要设置对应的环境变量。
第二个就是我们常见的一些比较Traden快的调试,可以使用对应的我们Traden直接提供的Auto2能力进行给出一类Traden,
自己找到一个最优的Traden。
也可以我们通过手条调整器材大小。
然后并且我们也提供了一些SugTraden能力去进行Traden快的增长。
然后还有第二点就是核内的优化。核内的优化其实场景会很多。
然后我这里就大概过一下,其实第一点就是我们有些生存不清合数类型,比如int64。
我们没有办法使用时量的处理单元,我们是能用Skader去计算。
这个时候性能可能是比较差的。
但这个时候我们可以通过分析我们对应的kernel,我们是否说我们一定要使用到int64。
比如我们的计算数据可以控制在int312的表持范围内,那我们就尽可能使用int32,然后尽可能使用cmd。
这样性能就会更好。然后第二个就是生存不清合的缝存操作。
就无法高效地用DMNDMN一般都是一些规律的缝存,连续的缝存。
它出现一系列,让出现一类像离散的或者间接的缝存。
这个时候我们知道我们在ALS代季的话它的性能会比较差。
这个时候我们就可以尝试使用有没有办法在kernel层面进行改写,尝试将一些非连续的轴转成连续的轴转再进行搬运。
然后就是我们的流水的运营不够,这个的话场景就比较多的。
不管是每个河内的流水还是说我们每个还是cv间的流水,我们都可以通过。
通过担子的改写并且或者我们尝试使用编辑器的hint都是可以尝试。
那还有就是核心优化。
像cv核的流水并行,cv核的1:20这两个我之前介绍了比较多,这里就不详细展开了。
然后我们的优化手段优化方式都已经有了,我现在讲一下我们的优化目标以及优化路线。
然后优化目标的话就是第一个,我们尽可能的把我们的ub或者我们local buffer给占满,尽可能减少搬运的次数。
这样的话我们每次都可以将我们的buff内部的空间使能使能起来,减少我们的搬运的次数。
这样的话也可以尽可能使能我们的算力。
然后避免列化操作其实就是我们的尽可能使用cmd,不要用skeleton之类。
然后第三点就是优化。
之前我也详细讲过了,尽可能让我们的cv变形起来。
优化路线的话其实就是第一步,我们肯定是使用调整我们客户内部的。
进展结构流程排布。
当然这个阶段的调整的话其实肯定是我们需要基于我们之前,
我们需要我们经过这些仿真的分析,流水的分析,Ii的分析,
然后再进行DSR层面的改写。
这个时候就可以用到了我们的一些高级API。
当然如果用户对算法非常清楚并且了解我们底层架构的话。
这一层面在DSR层面用我们的高级API是可以做到非常好的优化。
如果我们不扩展这些API的话,用户只能使用chleton社区自带的一些language。
那就无法深入到我们的生产地层,只能在一些计算结构的情况下。
计算结构的方面进行改写。
这里的优化的频率就比较大,就是我们天花板也比较小。
但是只能在我们的高级API之后,我们就可以尽可能释放我们的chleton30。
然后当我们在DSR层面通过我们的高级API应用改写,那层排布之后,发现达到了我们的优化目标。
这个时候我们就可以尝试将一些优化点集成到我们的边级底层,尽可能的泛化。
因为毕竟,虽然说我们的高级API
优化的天花板比较高
但是与此同时带来的複雜度也是比较高的
如果我们尽可能将优化点接生到我们的SMPI内部
这样的话用户其实就需要感知算法
就可以拿到一个比较好的性能
然后第三点应验层面的话
用户一般很难感知
我们都是在我们SMPI内部进行优化
好后面这些的话其实在上面的都已经介绍过了
就快速过去吧
然后分析方法在这里的话我就不详细介绍了
这里的话就是一些我们的一些工具
就是方便我们去可视化一些可视化坑脑
比如我们把一个坑脑拉到对应的profile里面
我们可以看到这个坑脑的总号式
然后并且在refine内部
并且在refine内部
我们可以过去到AIC的占比
AIV的占比
Gear的占比
然后这里的话就是我们的simulator
我们可以拿到对应的流水图
这里是Ir
就我们可以如果对底层
对Ir比较了解的话
可以通过Ir去进行分析
这四个其实就是我们寻找优化点的方法
然后通过这些分析最后就运用我们的高阶API进行分析的优化
这就是我们最终目的
然后最后我会我介绍一下一个之前我们使用高阶API我们生存扩展API进行优化的一个样例
然后这个样例其实也比较简单
我们内部也是说只是使能通过
可能的改写
使能的对应的CMD和对应的1比2能力
可以看到我们在这里用到了subjectID
就是我们我们的fact核的ID
就是我们在物理层面我们的cable核跟fact核比例是1比2
然后并且用这个subjectID进行了offset计算
这样的话就是我们每一个不同的核
就是不同的fact核会通过对应的索引拿到不同的数据
然后两并且两个fact核可以进行分析
平行的计算
然后在这里也可以看到我们使用先进行了一个fet操作
然后这个fet操作其实是一个高位离散轴的一个搬运
然后搬运完之后在ub内进行一个连续的拼接
拼接完之后我们就需要将这个数据再给到dot进行计算
然后这个时候我们手动插入了fet和cable核的核源同步
然后当这个cable核计算完之后
我们会进行一个submess进行一个继续一个fact计算
这个时候我们我们的fact核计算完之后又会将我们的数据给到cable核
这个时候我们又在这里插入了fet核和cable核的核源同步
并且这里的offset我们之前就用到的subbroke id
就是说我们这里的fet核都是进行1:2的切分
不需要编辑自己内部的分析
我们在科目的层面就进行了改写
这样的话我们就通过了一个改写的方式叫一个离散的cbmix章子
进行了一个1:2切分
这种场景下就是如果给到编辑之前是没有办法分析出来的
需要我们进行kable的改写才能进行实能
这个时候我们就可以使用我们的高级API
但是同时我们拿到了性能数据之后发现这种类型的kable
我们确实是应该实能力比较的优化
这个时候我们就会将这个场景集成到我们的SMPI内部
然后后面用户如果遇到类似场景
就不需要自己去手写
可以直接使用tryton
就是tryton社区自己原生的op就可以进行对应的意标是能
OK
那本次的介绍就到此为止
然后并且前面我们介绍的玩法一
已经有小伙伴在活动艺术页面底下评论的答案
本次直播互动的三道题答案是
ACCBAB
批评区全部答对的前五名小伙伴可以私信小数收利去交易
OK
然后我看到了有些小伙伴提到了一些问题
然后我可以回答一下
然后像封述他问到了tryton现在有文道吗
这个是有的
不管是SMPI还是trytonSend
我们在对应的代码仓上面都是有对应的文道
然后你可以直接去GitCode上面搜
或者trytonSend
感觉像tb的tick
tb的tick的话它会更加底层一点
因为tick的话你是写的对应的
就是它是对CCE指令对了一层抽象
你还是得了解直锚指令怎么用
但是tryton的话你这里除了像一些copy那几个CV的接口之外
其实你都不需要感知硬件内部的指令到底怎么使用
你只需要写对应逻辑
其实包括像Fix pipe和CopyUBTLE
这两个接口其实你还是只需要感知对应的天色和buff大小到底是多少
不用感知硬件内部到底是怎么去执行的
我觉得还是比tb tick应该肯定是写起来更加好写的
并且它的语义或者说用法都是基于tryton的
还有一个小伙伴叫毒饭不是饭
他问卡很好
但我是学生哪里可以
当前的话你可以去CAN社区有一些免费的算力可以直接去申请
有一个云上来地
这个的话你可以去CAN官网搜一下
当前是免费的
还有一个轻目里问SyncBlock Weight
为我们接触方的流水线是
PAPS在A2E3代际是跟PAP话是一样的
没有抽到降品的小伙伴也不要灰心
科学作业和学习笔记都有机会拿到降品
大家可以扫码报名CAN训练营
更多挑战及丰富降品来给大家
大家可以扫描屏幕上的奥文码预约下一场直播
每来几个观看的直播
还有者可以在b站搜索升腾CAN观看回放
以上就是今天马一全开特级人
直播前面我們下次再見